[Music]
house of the dragon
game of thrones prequel series is coming
in 2022 on hbo
it's based on george rr martin's book
fire in blood volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished fire and
blood volume 2 book
which tells the tale of the 300 years
long targaryen history
starting from aegon to conquer and
ending with the mad king
house of the dragons season 1 will
feature the most exciting time period of
the targaryen history
the targaryen civil war known as the
dance of the dragons
the series starts with viserys targaryen
played by an actor petty considine
sitting on the iron throne as the king
of westeros
his mount valerian the black dread king
viserys targaryen is chosen by the lords
of estrellas to succeed the old king
jahirus targaryen
at the great council at harrenhal a warm
kind and decent man
viserys only wishes to carry forward his
grandfather's legacy
but good men don't necessarily make for
great kings
the king has a famous brother about whom
entire westeros tells stories daemon
targaryen
the rogue prince played by an actor matt
smith
it's georgia martin's favorite targaryen
known as the prince of the city
lord flee bottom and the rogue prince
he's the most controversial man of his
lifetime
an audacious rogue prince and adventure
who seems made of good and evil in equal
measure
prince damon is the most experienced
warrior of his time and wields the
valyrian steel blade dark sister
a dragon rider whose dragon is
characters writings of westerosi
archmaester gives the best description
of daemon
it reads over the centuries house
targaryen has produced both great men
and monsters
prince daemon was both in his day there
was no man so admired so beloved and so
reviled in old westeros he was made of
light and darkness
in equal parts to some he was a hero to
others the blackest of villains
king viserys also has a daughter rhinera
targaryen
she will be played by an actress emma
darcy
princess rhaenyra targaryen cheered as
the realms delight
is the first born child of king viserys
the first targaryen
rhaenyra was king viserys the first only
living child by his first wife
queen emma of house serena at the age of
she was made her father's heir and grew
up expecting to become the first ruling
queen of estrus
rainer is a dragon rider whose mount was
xyrex
rhaenyra and daemon are together despite
the fact that their niece and uncle
since the king's first wife died the
king married ellison hightower
she is played by olivia cook with her he
finally gets male children
the oldest of which is aegon but still
aegon's half sister rhaenyra is older
and even though the king has male heirs
rhaenyra remains the official heir to
the drown
at first young rhaenyra and ellison got
along well but the rift grew between
them as soon as ellison produced her own
children for viserys the first
and clearly wanted them to succeed to
the throne instead of her
alice and born with theirs the first
four children
aegon ii aim and one eye there on the
daring and helina who became the sister
wife of aegon ii
the reason alice sent a miseries sweat
was alison's father
oro hightower played by ray seifens
who had been kind of the king in the
last few years of the long reign of king
jaehaerys the first targaryen
in 101ac otto brought the young alicent
to the royal court
where she cared for the aging king
jahiris eventually died in 103ac while
his scent was reading to him and was
succeeded by his grandson viserys the
first
the last but not least of the targaryens
from this time period we have princess
rhaenys known among the small folk as
the queen who never was
she's the granddaughter of jacharys the
first targaryen
and the cousin of isaiah is the first
targaryen in daemon targaryen
as her father was the prince of
dragonstone and she was his first born
child
many considered her as being next in
line for the iron throne
but upon quite a few unfortunate events
such as the death of her father
she was passed over the great council
voted for her cousin viserys to be the
new king
rhaenys married legendary corliss of
house valerian
known as the sea snake who will also
play a major role in the series
and he is played by an actor steve
tusson while the first few episodes will
pretty much be a calm before storm
in which we'll get to know all these
characters the second half
of the first season will see the
beginning of the most devastating war
westeros has ever seen
the dance of the dragons it all starts
when king viserys dies
and half of the kingdom sides with his
designated aeran era
while the other half sides with queen
alicent who pushes the claim of her son
aegon
we have the greens against the blacks
the greens are the factions that support
the claim of fagon the second targaryen
their rivals being the blacks who
support the claim of rhaenyra targaryen
both were named for the color of their
clothes worn during one tourney
the forced closeness of rhaenyras and
delis and children
increased animosity between the blacks
and the greens
the royal children and grandchildren
became dragon riders
and court visitors observed the dragons
of one faction
snapping and spitting flames at the
dragons of the other party
iserus dies in mid-season on the third
day of the third moon of 129 ac
during a nap in the red keep of king's
landing on his deathbed he refuses to
change the succession
and decrease his heir to be rhaenyra he
is found dead by a servant
who first goes to alicent to inform her
of yzeris's death
which proves to be a grave mistake as
ellison proclaims
aegon the king over the vicious of his
heirs at a time of her father's death
rainer is on dragonstone as is the place
for true air
the green thinking's landing ensure that
the news of viserys's death does not
reach rhaenyra
until her own supporters in the red keep
are dead or imprisoned
and dagon the second coronation had
already occurred
king viserys decorated rhaenyra to
succeed him but aegon the elder
the eldest son of his second wife alice
sent is instead crowned aegon ii by sir
christian cole
the lord commander of the kingsguard on
dragonstone rhaenyra learns about the
death of her father and the betrayal of
her siblings
rhaenyra in answer to aegon's betrayal
is crowned a queen at dragonstone and
swears revenge
this leads to a civil war between
rhaenyra and aegon
the dance of the dragons a war of
succession between aegon ii and his half
sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
throne the devastating civil war that
tore apart
the seven kingdoms the war lasted for
three years
and by the time it came to an end
thousands were dead
nearly all of the targaryen dragons had
been killed as well as many targaryens
themselves
it didn't start out right with war using
dragons and armies
but at first it was a war of ravens
rhaenyra makes her own council at
dragonstone the black council
participants are amongst others her
uncle husband
daemon her three eldest sons shakira's
lustris and joffrey
lord corliss valerian and his wife
princess rhaenys
during the council it's resolved that
while rhaenyra remains at dragonstone to
regain her health
prince daemon and characters will travel
to the riverlands
to make herring hole their base and
railing point for those loyal to
rhaenyra
house valerian will close off the gullet
blocking all shipping from blackwater
bay
princess rhaenys is convinced that
storm's end will declare for rhaenyra
since lord bormund baratheon the
deceased father of lord boros and
rhaenys's uncle
had always been a supporter of rhaenys
prince daemon is also convinced that
lady jane eyring
the maiden of the vale will bring her
support to their side
although they believe the north to be
too remote to play an important part in
the war
messages are to be sent to those lords
nevertheless
rhaenyra's sons themselves depart to
rally the lords to their side
with the eldest jacares visiting the
aryans of the erie
the manderlists of white harbor and the
starks of winterfell
rhaenyra's second son lucerus travels to
storm's end
prince daemon leads the first attack of
the war on harehole
which is conquered without bloodshed the
castle answers simon strong
yields when he sees daemon's dragon this
conquest leads the victories of the
blacks at the burning male and stone
hedge
and allow the river lords such as house
blackwood to gather at harrenhal
in the meantime jacarius gains lady iran
and the lords manderly borle
and sunderland and craig and stark to
rhaenyra's cause
with craigan allying through the pact of
ice and fire
towards the end of season 1 the first
battle between targaryens and their
dragons will occur which will set the
dark tone for the rest of the war
filled with blood fire revenge and grief
the dance tower shipbreaker bay losers
flies to storm's end
arriving before a gathering storm he
finds prince aemond one eye
and his dragon vegard already present
was there on his brother king aegon's
behalf to win the baratheon lord to his
side
prince eamon and lucerus had bad blood
even prior to this
as when they were younger luceries took
out a man's eye with a dagger in a fight
amen tries to provoke loose race into a
fight
insulting him calling him a strong
bastard but looser is thorn
not to fight or refuses him he delivers
his message to lord boris baratheon
but is refused and told to leave lord
baratheon prevents aemond from attacking
his cousin in the castle
but allows for the prince to follow him
mounted on his dragon aemon catches up
with loose race during a raging storm
the fight between the two dragons does
not last long
vagar being 5 times bigger has the
advantage and
airax falls broken rhaenyra collapses
when learning of luceri's death
prince daemon at harrenhal sends a raven
to his wife
promising that her son's death would be
avenged
using one of his friends from king's
landing his former lover and current
mistress
of whispers mizeria who is played by an
actress sonoya mizuno
daemon enlists the help of a former
sergeant in the city watch
known now only as blood and the red
catcher from the red keep
now known only as she's the two sneak
into the red keep using secret tunnels
and hidden doors
which brings them into the tower of the
hand their queen ellis scent is bound
and
gagged and her bed maid strangled when
queen
helena king aegon's sister wife and
their three children appear
blood and cheese close the doors and
tell haley not to choose which of her
sons will die
haley now reluctantly chooses mailer
because he's younger
but blood does the opposite and kills
the older prince instead
the two flee with the prince's head
leaving the others unharmed
and daemon proves his word to rhaenyra
and they hit back at king aegon
a son for a son this is the season 1
finale and it sets the tone for the
upcoming seasons filled with fire and
blood
revenge and grief deaths of targaryens
their dragons and their armies
ramin giovati the composer of game of
thrones epic music is back to compose
for all these epic scenes in house of
the dragon
if you like epic drama series filled not
only with epic battles between armies
and dragons
but also filled with court politics
betrayals and everything that made you
fall in love with the world of esros in
the first place
then you're going to love this game of
thrones prequel house of the dragon
begins filming in about 1 month
and will premiere in 2022 on hbo thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs
up and i hope to see you in the next one
peace